[Music]
one time when I was in college I went to
knocked on the bathroom it was last call
everyone was done but I knew that there
were two people who hadn't settle up
their tab and I had have an idea of
where they were I knocked on the door
and as I opened the door the guy turns
around and then proceeds to throw up all
over the girl that he is having sex with
that happened I was actually closing the
bar at one the place I worked in Hell's
Kitchen usually typical when your
closing bar or wiping everything down
and then all of a sudden three guys walk
in when the guys goes hey like are you
open my manager and I were both like
like actually really sorry we are closed
the registers are shut down like
everything like our bus is like turning
them off the floor like like we were
done when the guys turns around to leave
and he goes you don't know what you just
did and we're like wait what like what
like what just happen he was like that
was Bruce Willis he's just closed on and
I was like it was really resolved and so
we actually felt really bad the owner of
the bar ended up sending him about
tequila just to cut our bottle miss cow
just say sorry I feel terrible
I've got a great tip right so yeah I
closed the door on Bruce Willis so the
other day I actually had a group of four
people come in right off the bat the one
guy wanted to know what our most
expensive champagne was which is not a
question that you get very often I was
like Walden Dom Perignon like four
hundred and fifty five dollars a bottle
and he just went great we'll take two
that's such a strange way to just like
start balling out on your evening the
people he was with were like no no don't
do it he was like no I'm jay-z tonight
I'm balling out so I grabbed my manager
because I was like I think this is a
little suspicious he was like oh no if
you ordered it like let's do it let's go
by the end of the couple hours that they
were there the guy who had ordered the
champagne was like laid back his chair
just drinking straight out of the bottle
absolutely hammered you know that look
on someone's face and like they could
puke at any second that's the world he's
living in he tried to walk out without
paying
I grabbed my bouncer so fast and he was
just like oh come on
and I was like dude I have your credit
cards I'm gonna swipe it for this amount
and I'm gonna give myself 20% gratuity
but we caught him real fast and made him
pay and I'm sure even though that was
several days ago he's still hungover
I had this couple come in they were so
sweet guess it was a regular date with
David I said guy waited till she got
kind of got buzzed where she was like
semi walking straight and her heels she
went to the bathroom he's like hide this
ring in a red velvet cupcake that we
serve at that place so we all the
bartenders are like oh my god we're
about to be all set we're about the
camera we hide it in we put the candle
and the guy gets down on one knee he's
all excited you could tell he's like
nervous because all cameras and the
whole restaurant are on him and the
ladies like can we talk about this I was
like what do we do because we still have
to stay smiling I'm devastated he looked
like he was gonna cry oh poor baby I
guess the truth things out when you're
drunk right it was like how can I handle
that situation without laughing my god I
wanted to be part of it and Sylla when
English channels
[Music]